as we finally start to see just a kind
of a glimpse of warmer Spring weather
it's a good time really to check on your
garden eight news now's Brian well tells
us how the colds start to Spring has
impacted gardeners what you can do to
make the most of this weather
Bonnie Pointer and her husband recently
moved to Las Vegas but they weren't
ready for the weather especially this
year we were blindsided by how cold it
got here and so I think we're trying to
revive a couple of plants that we've put
in Brandon Fox the general manager at
Moon Valley Nurseries says they've had
to do more prep work this year A
peculiar start to the spring season some
plants are a little timid they don't
know if they should push the new growth
for this for the spring season yet and
others are flourishing and it's probably
the the best they've ever looked after
an unusually cold spring now is the time
to start planting from shrubs to trees
it's best to get these in the ground
before that hot summer weather hits
we kind of made some choices on our own
before we came to moon and and
um found out that they probably weren't
the best choices in the best location
fox says planting now will give your
plant the optimal amount of time to grow
roots before the heat for the current
plants in your yard get some fertilizer
Down nutritional water and trimming if
you tackle those three things you can
not only have a surviving landscape but
you can have a thriving landscape here
in the desert as for Bonnie we found the
one that was perfect for our yard so
we're looking forward to that
if you're wondering what to grow in your
yard right now best to ask the experts
at nurseries as everyone's yard is very
different some simple things to plant or
have on your patio can include some
herbs like basil chives Dill parsley
Rosemary arugula cilantro they do well
in our climate but again Ask the nursery